welcome to CBS this morning the House
Judiciary Committee launches a new round
of impeachment hearings in just a few
hours after Democratic lawmakers spelled
out why they believe President Trump
violated his oath of office the House
Intelligence Committee report yesterday
concluded the president quote sought to
pressure and induce Ukraine to announce
politically motivated investigations of
his rivals this morning the Judiciary
Committee will ask for law professors if
they believe the evidence against the
president meets the standard for
impeachment in London yesterday the
president called the inquiry unpatriotic
Nancy Cordes is in the room where this
morning's hearings will be held Nancy
what can we expect
well this morning's hearing is meant to
answer some basic but very important
questions
what is impeachment when is it justified
should it apply here the lawmakers and
the witnesses will be relying on a new
300 page report that lays out all the
evidence that has been gathered so far
in a party-line vote last night the
House Intelligence Committee released
all its findings to the House Judiciary
Committee the reports key finding that
President Trump used the power of his
office to apply increasing pressure on
the president of Ukraine to announce an
investigation into his campaign rival
Joe Biden he was willing to sacrifice
the national security of the United
States by withholding military aid and
diplomatic recognition in the form of
that White House meeting the report
describes a months-long campaign where
senior US officials including vice
president Mike Pence were either
knowledgeable of or active participants
in an effort to extract personal
political benefits sought by the
president I followed the directions of
the president we worked with mr.
Giuliani because the president directed
us to do so cell phone data shows the
president's personal lawyer Rudy
Giuliani made multiple calls to key
officials including the top Republican
on the Intelligence Committee Devin
newness
the calls dating back to the spring
raised questions about new NASA's role
in US policy in Ukraine the president
slammed the inquiry from London
publicans argued the report doesn't meet
the Democrats own bar for impeachment
there is nothing compelling there's
nothing overwhelming and the only
bipartisan we have vote we have had in
this house is not to move forward with
impeachment inquiry today for legal
experts will give their view CBS News
legal analyst Jonathan Turley is the
only witness selected by Republicans
he's expected to tell lawmakers in his
opening statement that it is possible
that a case for impeachment could be
made but it cannot be made on this
record
he explained that argument on CBS this
morning
last monitor all this thing is too
narrow it is it doesn't have a broad
foundation and it's an undeveloped
record back in 1998 at a similar hearing
Turley argued that the allegations
against President Clinton went to the
very heart of the legitimacy of his
office and did merit impeachment by the
house you can expect Anthony that some
of the other witnesses will make a
similar case against President Trump
today Nancy thank you we will bring you
the first House Judiciary Committee
hearing on impeachment in the CBS News
special report Norah O'Donnell will
anchor from Washington it begins at
10:00 a.m. 9:00 central and you can find
continuous coverage on our streaming
network cbsn